okay so let's go back to basics and look
at mobile communication standards which
are the target technology were actually
affecting here so back in 1999 we got to
G or GSM which kind of revolutionized
the way we communicate we were now able
to communicate through handheld devices
while staying mobile unfortunately A to
G has been considered broken for several
years now and further on we have 3G or
UMTS UMTS allowed us to browse the web
with a decent internet speed
unfortunately another standard that was
being considered broken today 4G is the
most adopted standard and it's basically
considered secure but I in this talk I'm
going to show you that it isn't so we're
establishing that 4G is the target
technology we're attacking here the way
we're going to do it is by using an MC
catcher so first things first an MC is
the permanent identifier of a 4G
subscriber okay so it's kind of like a
client secret without an expiration date
and an MC catcher is essentially a fake
base station which act as a completely
normal base station and the DMC catcher
it attracts cell phones to connect to
the MC catcher and once the cell phones
are attracted to to dream sketcher
you can do various attack against
different cell phones so the first
attack I'm going to show you is simple
MC catching and as I mentioned when you
have the M sketcher you need phones to
connect to your MC catcher and it's
defined in the LTE standardization that
cell phones perform handover based on
prioritized frequencies so by configure
my MC catcher with the highest
prioritized frequency among the nearby
base station all the phones will
automatically connect my MC catcher and
when it does that it sends some tracking
area update request because it sees a
new base station this part doesn't
contain any useful information for me as
an attacker
so I'm just rejecting this message when
the phone receives this rejection it
initiates a an attack request message
and in this message the attach requests
it sends its identity unfortunately this
is only the temporary identity which I'm
no interest in I only want the permanent
one so I returned with an identity
request requesting the phone to send
send it permanent identity DMC the phone
sees no problem with this and just
passes the MC along in the identity
response message and voila you have DMC
so the final step is to disconnect the
phone you're doing this in an attached
reject and in the attached project
you're attaching a rejection course and
in this case I'm attaching the no
suitable cells in this area this
disconnects from the Imps catcher and
the phone jumps straight back to the
original legitimate network so you might
think ok now I have the MC now what with
the MC you can for instance initiate
phone calls you can send text messages
based on another subscriber ok and you
can also do location disclosure you can
track movements you know if when you're
getting all the MCS you know where they
are located and for instance I can bring
this instigator near your workplace
I can fact when a person enters the
building and when he leaves if you want
to take it even further I can bring this
MC catcher to your home your private
house I can detect whether you're home
or not and if you're that kind of person
you can ok there's nobody here I can do
a break in stuff like that
the second attack I wanna show you is
denial of service it's the exact same
message flow as the previous one
I've only included the first and the
last message here because the important
thing we're doing here is the when in
when you're disconnecting the phone from
your main MC catcher because in this
scenario I'm attaching our rejection
course called LTE and non LTE services
allowed in the attached reject
so when the phone receives this message
it goes like okay there's no 2g note 3g
and no 4G the phone goes into ghost mode
it won't search for any other base
station until is rebooted yeah and the
the vulnerability here is that none of
these messages have encryption nor
integrity protection so that's that's
the that's a weakness error so the third
attack I want to show you is to
downgrade to 2g or 3G again the exact
same message flow I'm just changing the
rejection cost parameter which is in the
attach reject message so this time I'm
saying LTE service is not allowed so it
won't search for LTE it will go to 2g
and 3G remember I told you that 2g and
3G both of them are broken so for
instance if the phone jumps to 2g
there's no mutual authentication into G
so you can do a full man-in-the-middle
attack with an MC catcher you can
basically sniff all messages all phone
calls that goes between the phone and
the real network cool right
so if you want to try this attack
yourself if you want an MC catcher you
have two choices the first one is to buy
a stingray - this is basically a MC
catcher out of the box the problem here
is that you have to work in the FBI to
actually be able to buy one the other
thing is that the price is almost one
hundred and thirty five thousand US
dollars which which in Norway is
basically this equivalence of two
Tesla's so but if you like fancy cars
and still want an MC catcher you have a
alternative alternative which is to
build your own by using a USRP a radio
peripheral which costs seven hundred and
sixty five US dollars which is the
equivalent of Elon Musk flamethrower
probably have more fun with the
flamethrower than the Tesla's but so
this is what I did in my experiment I
built my own I used on USRP as I
mentioned from ethics research yeah
from Etta's research which handle all
the transiting part for the logic I use
the open source interface open source
software called open-air interface
simple right so how common are actually
MC catchers in real life according to
the new region security police it's not
there's no evidence that there actually
exists MC catcher in Oslo not going to
comment on that article but if you're
ever going to use one do it in a foreign
a cage so you won't attack innocent
subscribers so I'm gonna turn with this
live now just get it by my boss it's
right over there I just want to freak
him out so hold your horses because if I
were to do this I would probably end up
I would probably get a lot of trouble
and possibly end up in jail because
you're you're breaking breaking the law
you're doing a lot of crimes
you're stealing identities you're
stealing the MC you're doing mass
surveillance you're monitoring person
movements and all of these are part of
breaking the private the privacy of the
subscriber so how can you as subscribers
prevent yourself from such attacks
I'm afraid I'm bad news there there's
really nothing you can do it it's
totally up to the mobile operators and
even the mobile operators are limited
because this is a vulnerability that
exists in the LTE specification so on
that bombshell this was hacking 4G and
how to get arrested in ten minutes I'm
Kristin thank you
[Applause]